[Musique]
se vacciner fait un choix personnel
ça doit pas être obligatoire alors en
fait c'est pas si simple que ça quand on
se fait vacciner
c'est pour éviter d'attraper une maladie
et on sait que déjà ça s'est compliqué
pour pas mal de gens parce que ça
revient à prendre des médicaments pour
une maladie qu'on a pas pour pas la voir
justement ça s'appelle de la prévention
on a du mal avec la prévention bien
manger pas fumer pas trop boire pas
rouler trop vite on a du mal mais se
faire vacciner contre une maladie fait
aussi éviter de la transmettre
et dans le cas de certaines maladies ça
veut dire éviter une épidémie et tous
les problèmes qui vont avec
genre de handicap ou la mort et pour
être sûr d'éviter une épidémie il faut
que suffisamment de personnes soient
vaccinés sinon ça marche pas et
aujourd'hui les seules maladies pour
lesquelles on arrive à 95 % de personnes
vaccinées
c'est celles pour lesquelles la
vaccination est déjà obligatoire ça
s'appelle la santé publique est c'est
fait pour protéger tout le monde et
notamment ceux qui peuvent pas se faire
vacciner parce qu'ils ont une
contre-indication médicale
c'est un acte citoyen en fait la société
la communauté elle te protège avec la
sécu et plein d'autres trucs tu te
protège et tu protèges la communauté
donc et pas juste une histoire
personnelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]